The results of this research were staggering.
Diagnostic accuracy increased from 39% to 91% for
the two dimensional model shown here.
In terms of perception, this should make sense.
The two dimensional model readily reveals all portions of the arteries,
while the three dimensional model can hide links in the artery from view.
Some might argue that the 3D model can be rotated, but it's important to
note that the 2D model can be viewed all at once within the span of the eye.
This allows us to make comparisons more quickly and easily.
I think one of the key takeaways from this research,
is that simple visualizations are generally better.
You can read more about this visualization and
all of Michelle's research in the instructor notes.
For a Readers Digest version, I recommend looking at the slides she
put together for the 2011 InfoVis conference.